c'est à peu près vis-à-vis où on aurait
l'entrée on se retrouve donc ici
est ce qu'on propose c'est d'aller
ouvrir des gradins cet endroit les
architectes qui ont été choisies pour la
rénovation du biodôme veulent qu'il soit
plus accueillant
il souhaite aussi que les visiteurs
puissent enfin avoir une vue de haut sur
les quatre écosystèmes
c'est un espèce de belvédère qui en
mezzanine fait qu'on peut se promener
faire le tour et donc d'avoir maintenant
l'accès de le rendre public une montre
et de free un nouveau point de vue sur
les épaules dès janvier 2018
les visiteurs pourront donc jouir d'une
vue en plongée
d'autres espaces seront dégagés comme
ici pour que les visiteurs puissent
mieux voir l'habitat du lynx les plus
grands changements surviendront dans le
monde polaire on va agrandir l'habitat
des manchots les vedettes du bio dont
les zones subarctiques vont être
complètement revu et on va ouvrir
l'habitant on va pouvoir être à
proximité avec les les macareux on va
sentir le fois on va entendre les
oiseaux
faute d'obtenir le financement de 45
millions de dollars de québec
la rénovation du biodôme tout comme la
reconstruction de l'insectarium ont été
retardés lorsque le grunge québec pour
ses propres raisons décidé de solliciter
du projet on ne pouvait pas le laisser
tomber
on avait des projets de qualité on
voulait continuer on promet que le
jardin botanique l'insectarium et le
planétarium vont mettre le paquet en
2017 pour faire oublier le chantier du
biodôme pour le 375e effectivement 3d
édition restées ouvertes et les
touristes vont être très heureux de voir
la programmation on la prépare pour 2017
on ne veut surtout pas parler de
rendez-vous raté pour 2010 est on espère
plutôt que le biodôme rénové pourra
ensuite accueillir au delà d'un million
de visiteurs chaque année ici anne
louise despatie radio canada montréal